This program is for educational purposes
only. The content is not intended to
diagnose, treat, cure, or prevent any
diseases, nor is it intended to take the
place of your primary care physician.
The statements in this program have not
been evaluated by the FDA. Testimonials
are shared as individual experiences of
the individual. Results vary and may not
be typical. We do not make any claims
regarding health or income. As an
empowered individual, you do have
options available. We are honored to
continue to share the teachings of a
founding father of the science of
epigenetics, Dr. Joel Wallik, Bachelor
of Science in Plant and Soil Sciences,
Doctor of Veterary Medicine, four post
doctorates in pathology, naturopathic
doctor.
This program is for educational purposes
only. The content is not intended to
diagnose, treat, cure. Hello and welcome
everyone to Daily with Doc and Becca. My
name is Ruth Ellen Sanchez and I'm going
to be your hostess today and um today's
show is sponsored by dailywithdoc.com
and is for educational purposes only and
it's not meant to treat, diagnose or
cure any diseases nor is it intended to
take the place of your primary care
physician. The statements in this
program have not been evaluated by the
FDA nor have um sorry testimonials are
shared as individual experiences of the
individual. Results may vary and may not
be typical. We do not make any claims
regarding health or income. As an
empowered individual, you do have
options and that's one of the reasons
why we're here to help you explore your
options. Also, if somebody referred you
to this program, please make sure to get
back with them because they are going to
be your primary point of contact. And if
you need to talk to a holistic health
coach and you're not working with
somebody else, please call us at
855-9493377.
And today we have the amazing Dr. Lisa
Singleary, who is going to give us an
amazing presentation on what color is
your urine and what does that mean?
So, I'm going to go ahead and spotlight
Dr. Singleary and bring her on the
screen with me.
And there we go.
Welcome, Dr. Lisa. I'm so excited to
have you here.
>> Thank you, Ruth Ellen. I was so excited
when I saw your name on my screen and I
was like, "Oh, is calling." Yes. So,
you're doing such an amazing job and I'm
so thrilled to be here.
>> Thank you so much. We're so thrilled to
have you here and I enjoyed watching
your um podcast on your YouTube channel
about the kidneys. So, please give a
plug to your podcast to your YouTube
channel.
Well, Dr. Lisa Singleary or at Dr. Lisa
Singleary is my channel and I will have
a
QR code at the end that you can scan to
get right to my channel, but I do um at
least once a week u health related
podcasts and I'm just having a ball.
>> That's good. And we can tell you're
having fun with what you do
>> cuz
>> and oh let me update my contact make it
um drl lisa singleary.com.
>> Okay
my last uh time here
uh there were there was a broken link or
something. I think I tra track tracked
down all the links. So, I think
drlisary.com,
>> okay,
>> is the best way to
>> explore a little bit more about me.
>> Yes. And you're fun to explore and
you're so knowledgeable. We love it. You
love it.
>> So, I'm gonna stop talking. I'm gonna
let you take over.
>> I can't wait to hear what you're going
to say. So, thank you so much.
>> Thank you. Well, um related to my weekly
webinars
which is called the total transformation
secrets live zoom
uh where and the replay is on YouTube.
So, but the last few episodes I've
gotten into some area that I really
love. So, uh if I get the numbers right,
I think webinar
I better not say the numbers. I'm going
to say 67. I think is when I introduced
Ernie the arythraite
and he's the first character of my
superheroes of science. And um we just
took u a just a great overview I think
of what the ariththraite does. An
ariththraite is a red blood cell, right?
throw means red and sight means cell.
And then the next which was webinar 68
we took a dive into the kidneys and not
only or not the whole kidney but just
one little area of the kidney that's
called the glomemeilus and that was
called the great body traffic jam
because the glomemeilus
is an area where your capillaries are at
extreme risk
for multiple things to happen. And once
you understand what's going on inside
that capillary, inside the glomemeilus,
it gives you an idea of how important it
is to have your blood pressure under
control and to have your blood sugar
under control. And why is it that so
many people that have a normal uh or um
an abnormal sorry blood sugar have an
abnormal
uh kidney or have if you have an
abnormal blood pressure you have a
chronic kidney disease. So, and then
when they work together, it's it's um
a
vortex of, you know, of a bad situation.
What do they call that? Vicious cycle.
That's what that's that's the V word I
was looking for. So, we want to break
the vicious cycle. But we started with
the beginning of the blood going into
the kidney.
Today we're going to talk about what
comes out of the kidney, which is the
urine and
the stuff that goes on in between
is amazing. But I can't go through all
the stuff that's in between today. So,
we're just going to talk about the
output today and then stay tuned for
future
uh webinars where I will dig into
what's called the renal tubules.
And the tubules
are the
amazing amazing structures that turn the
filtrate
that we found you know in the
glomemeulus
into the urine that actually comes out.
It is amaz it's amazing. But we're going
to talk about urine today particularly
the color
of the urine. So, I'm going to
I used to love it when that share button
was green, but here we go.
We are going to share.
Thank you for giving me the co-host
power. I love it. And we're talking
today. What color is your urine?
And my source article today, you know, I
love me somealthline.com
and Healthline indeed has an article
called urine colors explained and I put
the link at the bottom. I hope you can
see it. Um, but it's
healthline.com/health
urine
color-chart.
And this article, I I I'm going to show
you a couple more slides from this
article. It's a really really good
article. I encourage you to screenshot
the QR code if you can't um you know,
just grab the screenshot if you can't
actually activate the QR code from what
you're watching on.
But one of the things I love about the
article is it has this color chart and
it has 10. We only see five here, but 10
different colors
of urine. So there's this QR code is for
the chart.
I mean, it's not for the chart, it's for
the article, but I just I just put it
up. I'm going to give it to you one more
time, too, because I really want you to
get this article.
And it also has a YouTube short.
And I love this short. It's only, you
know, 24 seconds, something like that,
but they talk about some of the colors.
So, I I just loved this particular
article and it has another article
that's or you might have seen it has
other articles that are related. So, you
can learn a lot about your urine just
hanging out just from that one QR code.
So, but this is an a example of or an
illustration of my health journey
through the years. And I just wanted to
show you that
because in order for me to go from the
picture on the left
to the picture in the middle,
I'll just say this. It took one
multivitamin, multi-mineral
product,
and that one product contained 87
out of the 90 essential nutrients.
Some of you already know what it is, but
in 8 months, I went from the picture on
the left to the picture in the middle.
Then I added the rest of the 90 and some
keto, some learning about the good food,
bad food list. And you know, I'm still
on health journey today, but
this is this was my start to learning
the power of nutrition.
And from that experience, I developed
the five M of total transformation.
mindset, macronutrients,
micronutrients, motion, and measurement
because we got to keep track.
So, I am Dr. Lisa Singleary. I'm a
retired
board certified family physician. I have
the privilege of being a certified
holistic health coach.
I specialize in total transformation,
but a lot of that stems from
um weight uh issues and I try to help
people to
be on a sustainable
weight loss journey
and I love as you saw that we were
talking about a scientific article
today. I love taking these scientific
peer-reviewed articles and putting them
into plain language so that everyone can
understand and
um apply that information to their
health journey. Uh I do have a masters
in public health. A lot of people don't
know what M PH is um but I did I
received that at the John's Hopkins
University. I got my MD at Howard
University College of Medicine, my CWC
from the Institute of Holistic Health,
and those are just the three that I kind
of keep around. I have some others as
well, but my thrill is sharing this
knowledge with you. And just to let you
know, there was a time in my life that I
needed a miracle. Now, we don't talk
about miracles and health and wellness,
but this is also my reminder to give a
little disclaimer. You already gave me a
a disclaimer for the show, Ruth Ellen,
which is great. Um, but I just want to
say I am not a second opinion.
I am not covered by your insurance. I'm
not here to fight with your doctor
so much.
But hopefully this will be educational
and maybe a little entertaining and um
like I said, I'm just thrilled to be
here. So, we're going to cover today
uh these four main areas.
Uh
the hydration like your baseline, what
do we normally,
you know, what are the limits of our
normal looking urine?
What colors can we ignore? That's those
are the false alarms. What colors are
red flags?
And you know, what can we do to empower
ourselves with this information?
So, where does the color come from in
the earth? Well, it comes from a few
places.
the uh your stomach and your gut, your
the pigments in your food are chemicals
that your body has to deal with. And the
first place uh they go
is to the liver. And the liver does a
lot to process anything that you
swallow, anything that you eat or drink.
First stop is the liver. I should do a
show about that. That's called the first
pass
effect. The liver gets the first pass
and then what the liver once the liver
says okay
these things are good these things are
bad but these things we need to
transform
um and then the results go into the
bloodstream.
Um then after circulation for
elimination it'll eventually get to the
kidneys.
Uh uh so the liver and bile ducts
depending on the uh conditions
they can
in they can give a brownish color to the
urine. Um the kidneys that's where
everything happens. We're going to have
an increasing
understanding of what happens in the
kidneys over the next weeks.
But if there's damage in those delicate,
vulnerable capillaries, then things can
get filtered out
of the blood that aren't supposed to be
filtered out. Meaning there's damage in
the if you think of it as a civ or a
filter there's if the civ is damaged
then it doesn't function. It doesn't
keep
what you know what's in the bloodstream
stays in the bloodstream right quote
unquote.
Uh and then the bladder
once the kidneys are done with all the
processing
that liquid goes down into the bladder
to be eliminated. But if it sits in the
bladder too long or if there is any kind
of bleeding in the bladder or if there's
infection in the bladder then um you
know that can show in the urine as well.
So, here's the baseline.
There's a natural yellowess to urine.
And it might be diluted. It might be
more concentrated,
meaning you're dehydrated. I talk about
people walking around like
um
potato chips, right? We're dehydrated a
lot. And sometimes we don't even realize
it. And the urine is our main clue. So,
we want to be more on the pale side. So,
think of diluted lemonade
as opposed to
um light beer or
um iced tea. That's that's one of our
warning ones. But normally, we want to
be in the yellow area. Now if we're
talking about and I'll mention this
later but
uh many of us
when I say us people uh that are
taking that are on our on a supplement
journey many of us have more of an
orange look to our urine because of the
different supplements that we might be
uh taking. All of that is within a
normal
range, but we can optimize it by
increasing our hydration.
So, um, we could have, like I said,
things that we eat that are pigmented.
So those pigments actually
some of them have very important
properties in our bodies. Um
as far as antioxidants
um the phytonutrients, you might have
heard that word, but there's a reason
the plants develop
some of these phytonutrients because
they can't run away from predators. They
can't run away when the wind blows or um
you know they they have to withstand
their environment and so they develop
these antioxidants
that uh help them to repair oxidative
stress and we can borrow those
antioxidants by eating these super
fruits and super juices.
But some those pigments can
uh end up in our urine.
Some medications
give a different color to our urine. And
this is what we want to make sure we we
know that there are some colors in the
urine that are red flags.
And our body is really trying to tell us
that something is wrong. So let's dig
in.
So the ranges of normal
um clear union clear urine
we don't want it to be absolutely clear
because that could mean you are over
hydrated and you might be um flushing
out the electrolytes that you need. So
it can be a problem if you're drinking
lots if you're not drinking lots of
water and your urine is clear clear then
there might be a problem right because
we want to have some color to the urine.
Now, neon yellow.
Um, massive doses of B vitamins and some
different uh some different nutrients
can make your urine have a little glow.
I love that glow. Right. And when we're
sharing the supplements with people, we
can that's kind of a test. We could ask,
we can prepare them ahead of time to
say, you know, your urine's going to
change color
or we can wait and say, uh, if you
notice anything, and if they don't
notice anything, they're probably not
taking their their supplements. So,
u, but I like to prepare people.
Now, if we're in the red or pink zone,
again, it can be dietary, beets, right,
rhubarb, blueberries,
um, medication side effects, but
red or pink urine can be a medical red
flag, meaning there could be blood cells
in the urine. And if that's the case,
then we really have to look at what's
going on with the kidney function,
especially at the glomearials.
So if you think you might have blood in
your urine,
then um
I'm going to share with you something
you can do to kind of test that theory.
And if if the test shows that there's
blood, then you want to track that down.
But guess what? It's almost
always
going to be blood pressure, blood sugar,
or a combination of the two. So, it's
really important just get to the basics
of
um the good food, bad food list. get to
the basic of avoiding the bad foods so
we can protect
the glomemeriol line of the kidney, the
c those
high pressure capillaries.
Orange alert again.
Uh when you are
dehydrated,
then that's going to definitely change
the color of your urine and it can push
into
the amber looking or a deep orange
looking depending on what medications
you take or what um supplements you
take.
a red flag. However, if your orange if
you have orange urine and light colored
stool. So that combination
there can be something happening with
your bile duct issues. So again, we're
going to we're going to um try to
sort the forest from the trees a little
later, but
um one of the things you can do is make
sure you increase your hydration and see
does hydration alone
uh settle out that color or or dilute
out that color.
Now, sometimes there are just some
strange colors in your urine, such as
blues, greens, even other colors. They
can be related to some supplements,
some foods, but usually it's something
unusual
such as methylene blue or um you know
dies from kidney tests or
some rare conditions can uh produce
uh this bluish or greenish
tinge.
to the urine
teacolored urine.
We used to hear about this in medical
school,
but when you see it, it is. And I'll
tell you one day. So, I left medicine
to take care of my parents. I was their
primary caretaker for eight years. And
one day my dad
showed me his urine and it looked like
iced tea. And I said, "Dad, we got to
go. We got to get this checked." Because
and he did have kidney issues. He had
high blood pressure. He had diabetes. So
he was a textbook
case for
um having his glomeili at risk. And so
we were able to get him under control. I
I marvel at him sometime because he
didn't develop diab di diabetes until or
he wasn't diagnosed I'm not sure exactly
when he developed it but he wasn't
diagnosed with diabetes until he was 85.
So we had to get you know we had to get
some education in him and take teach him
how to use his diet properly and hydrate
and things like that. and he did amazing
for
um five or so years before he actually
passed. So there there are things we can
do to make the situation better in our
kidneys especially I got to say it again
with the pressure and with the sugar
but when you see this it is when you see
teacolor urine it is a it can be I'll
say that it can be a medical red flag.
Now, there's some people um that little
note at the bottom, this is rare, but
there's some people that
um their muscles will start to break
down and they have some something called
rabdomiolysis
and
that will make the urine um this dark
brown or this tea colored urine and um
that's something to watch, but usually
that will pass
relatively quickly,
especially with rest and hydration.
Okay? So, it's not also it we don't just
look at the color of the urine, but the
texture
of the urine. Is it
thick? Is it cloudy? Is it foamy? Right?
These can represent different
conditions. Um, I would say especially
watch out for foamy urine in diabetics
because or or you know or high blood
pressure because that is an indication
that protein
is leaking out of the glomemeili
and
um
you know that protein is causing the
foaming of the urine. So that's a that's
an indication that something is wrong.
Whether it's from
high pressure or whether it's from
glucose, high sugar damaging the
capillaries. But those capillaries are
extremely vulnerable.
And we especially don't want to see this
in pregnant women because there's
something called preeacclampsia
that um this could be a sign of. So we
have to keep we have to keep an eye out.
So, um, early warning signs.
A lot of times our kidneys are trying to
tell us something and sometimes our
kidneys will give us information before
we actually feel it, right? So, we might
not have symptoms,
but we want to watch out if we're making
less urine or if we're making if we're
having to urinate too frequently,
especially at night. um
brain fog, insomnia, fatigue, any
swelling, you know, in your ankles, but
when it swells in your eye areas
especially, we want to find out what's
going on. And muscle cramping, like it
could be an electrolyte imbalance, but
it could be um something a little more
dramatic happening in your kid in your
kidneys.
When we get further past those early
warning signs, then again, we want to
look for darker urine, foamy urine, um
maybe blood in the urine, um and all of
these things.
Again, this is not to scare you. This is
to make you aware
that your kidneys, your urine can be
telling you a lot. not just how much
hydration you have, but there are other
things that your urine can be showing
you. And so, here's a little chart. So,
I'm going to give you just a little
time. You can screenshot this
and I think
um maybe on Saturday
I will you put this chart because I'll
talk about this on Saturday.
Um, I'll put this chart as a download.
Um,
but just to give you an idea of the
different things that can go on if you
see these different colors in your urine
and
um, what can we do about it?
Well, here's a little flowchart.
So if you notice a a weird color,
you want to ask yourself, did you eat
beets? You know, if you saw the a red
color in your urine, did you eat a
highly pigmented food
or start a new medication or a new
supplement? If the answer is yes,
then
wait 48 hours, hydrate,
and um if it's from the food, then um
you know, it should go away within a
couple days. If it's from a supplement
that you're taking that a new supplement
or a new medication, then it's not
necessarily going to go away, but the
hydration should help.
If you have high pigment in your urine
and you have not
started a new medication or
um
uh eaten a highly pigmented food,
drink some a large glass of water, get
some rest,
and wait a little bit. And if after a
couple days it's still a it's still a
weird color, call the doctor. Right. So,
we give it some time.
But the other thing you can do is Oh,
let me see that note down there. Skip
the wait and call immediately if the
urine is cloudy or foamy during
pregnancy or if you suspect blood. All
right. This is what we're going to do.
Oh,
it's not on this slide. I mean, it's not
in this slide deck. All right. So what
we're going to do
in this algorithm,
we're going to be able to add a
measurement. You know, measurement is
one of the five M's. And the measurement
we're going to add is we can get urine
test strips.
You can go right to the drugstore or,
you know, grocery store, pharmacy.
They're all they're all over the place.
You don't need um prescriptions for most
of them.
You just get a urine. And there are you
have to watch the strips. There are some
strips only have one or two things that
you can test. Um actually I have a I
think I have a picture of some urine
test strips. So once I stop the slides,
I'll see if I can pull that picture up.
Um but what you want to do is get this
the strip that's called a multi-stick.
So dex dextro sticks will only test
sugar which is important but the
multisticks will test for blood. They'll
test for your pH. They'll test for your
sugar. They'll test for multiple
um things that can be in your urine. and
it gives you a color spectrum to see,
okay, this is really high or this is
it's a little colorful, but it's not um
it's it's kind of on that low side,
closer to normal. So, um
so we don't just have to go by our
memory of what we ate or
a hunch. Um, we also have a way that we
can test and I love that. Right. So,
all right. So, I also want to share the
five steps to nutritional completeness
because it's being able to give your
body all of the 90 essential nutrients
where
your body is going to thank you. and on
a cellular level, it's going to be able
to
function to the max um of its
uh of its ability. So, step one, we we
want to avoid foods that cause
inflammation
and oxidative stress.
Now, we've talked about a lot of foods
today that have a lot of color. We like
those foods, right? They're going to be
on the good food list. So, we want to be
aware
when we are eating foods that are highly
colorful and see what our urine shows um
after we eat them or if we see our urine
abnormal, think back, okay, what did I
eat? But the good food, bad food list is
our number one tool for step one for
avoiding the bad foods.
Step number two, we want to get the 90
essential nutrients.
Step number three, and I'm going to
share those next next slide,
antioxidants, adaptogens,
anti-inflammatories. So, our bodies
are designed to handle a certain amount
of oxidative stress. Our bodies create a
certain amount of oxidative stress. But
when you add the modern diet, the modern
exposure to radiation,
um, chemicals,
uh, nanoplastics,
all these things cause oxidative stress
in our bodies and
it's causing more stress in our bodies
are designed to handle. And so we can
give them help by giving antioxidants,
adaptogens,
anti-inflammatories.
Step four, digestive health. Our gut
lining has to be normal to function and
has to be um has to not be inflamed in
order to function normally. So an
inflamed gut does not function normally.
And that means even if you're taking in
the good nutrition,
your body can't absorb it. So we want to
be very um mindful of the h the health
of our gut lining
and of our gut microbiome. Our gut
microbiome is so important because
uh it's not just a bunch of bacteria in
your poop. They are active producing
substances that affect our whole bodies
including our brain. So all it's all
connected right. Step five, winter, not
winter wonderland, wellness wonderland.
This is where we have targeted
supplementation,
brain support, joint support, kidney and
bladder support, um lymph support, you
name it, right? And it massage therapy,
Reiki,
uh infrared
lights,
all of these things that are available
to us um in our wellness journey,
they're on step five. But that
rests on the foundation
of the first four steps. Just a look at
the 90 essential nutrients.
I try to emphasize the word essential
because it has a specific
meaning really a double meaning. So when
something is essential what do you think
it means you need it right? But
medically,
biochemically,
the word essential means your body can't
make it. So in order to get these 90
essential nutrients, you have to take
them in. And we can't rely on our food
anymore. So, you know, thankfully we
have amazing
plant-based supplements uh or natural
supplements,
cellular
nourishing supplements that we can bring
to the table.
Okay. So, my webinars, I've been saying
it. I would love for you to join me live
on Saturdays at 11:00 a.m. Eastern.
And so you can scan this QR code to
register
for Total Transformation Secrets. And
this will you'll get all the information
for how to join live.
And
every Saturday once we do the live show
on Saturday morning, I put the replay up
Saturday evening at 900 p.m. Eastern on
YouTube and it just stays there after
that. But the first show
on Saturdays at 9:00 p.m. I am actually
in the chat and you know we have a lot
of nice uh interaction.
I'm just noticing I need to change the
slide. Okay, I put that on my to-do
list. But we have a lot of nice
interaction in the chat in the premere
the first showing on YouTube. So, this
uh QR code goes right to my channel.
All right. So, those are the secrets,
but I do want to say, let's see. We're
going to
exit.
Uh, let me see.
Yes,
let me know if you can see this. I just
Googled urine test strips. I think you
can still see this. So there are all
kinds of strips,
right? So you want to buy the strips
that are
what we call multi. So there are keto
strips, they only have one or two
testers on the pad. Well, the ketos only
have one, but keto diet sticks might
have two, but the multis have many.
And that will be including blood, uh,
like I said, pH,
um, different different measurements
that will help us determine if our
urine's looking a different color,
should we be concerned?
All righty.
So,
I see a hand. I can take some questions,
right? the time. Oh, 8:42. Okay.
>> Yes. Yes. Mary, go ahead. Thank you so
much, Dr. Lisa. Mary, go ahead.
>> Okay. Hi, Dr. Lisa. That was uh very
very informative. I I learned uh
actually quite a bit in the in the
presentation. Uh a couple of questions.
One is um I did have a client
that took uh started a new started
taking the BTT. They took it in the
tablet form.
>> Mhm.
>> And I didn't think they would get the
different color urine. You know, mostly
I thought it would come more in the uh
powder which we turn into liquid which
would be easier to get a different urine
color. But she did. She got a um darker
yellow I would say to maybe a light
orange.
>> Sure.
>> Which fit, you know, kind of fits in
line with Yes. We're taking a new
product and uh that that will likely
stay. Um but she went to her doctor. She
wanted to ask about the, you know, the
urine color and the change and, you
know, is that normal? What should I
think about it? And I, you know, I told
her, "Yes, it is normal." But her doctor
said, um, well, she took a look at the
bottle, you know, of what she was
taking. She's like, well, you don't need
all those B vitamins, so I recommend you
cut back. And of course, she was taking
tablets, so she could cut back to the
the number. And I said, okay. Of course,
the doctor's prescribing her lots of
things to manage metabolic syndrome, but
uh from a prescription standpoint. So,
um, what would you say about that, uh,
interaction and and does she really need
to cut back on the B vitamins?
Obviously, Dr. Wallick put these
formulas together for a reason, but that
was what her medical doctor told her.
>> Yeah. So, um, one, the formulation is
based on
decades of research, right, from Dr.
Well, including or primarily
uh autopsy research,
which means he's looking at the tissues
and he's looking at the cells
of all of these animals and people that
supposedly died of natural causes,
>> right? And found out that those are not
natural. So the basis of the formulation
is
hard science
and he has the um
Dr. Glidden calls it reductionist. He he
does not
uh have the reductionist philosophy
where you just look at one thing. Um it
takes a village. It takes a village of
um supplements. It takes a village of
organs to have everything running
together. So, um, but if I could show I
have a little chart,
uh, that might help to
talk about
the
powder versus the tablets. Mhm.
>> And I cuz and I I don't know why they
gave them the same name, but
in one serving of powder,
our organic whole food blend, 5700
milligrams.
Four tablets, 800 milligrams.
Amino acids, 575 versus 100. So, the
tablets have nowhere near the nutrition
that the powder does.
>> Right.
>> Right. So, um I could see why
maybe some people don't have
exactly the amount of color in their
urine that they do get with the powder,
but it's there, right? they do have um
these complexes that give color to the
urine. So, but the
what the doctor said
I believe is uninformed.
>> Yeah.
>> Right. And we are taught, we when I say
medical alopathic physicians, we are
taught that you're just peeing out
expensive urine. We are not taught that
it's an insurance policy for your body.
I don't know if I can say that that but
your body and I love this you know I'll
say for me when I'm under stress
my urine is not as
dark
>> because and my interpretation of that is
my body is using more of the BTT.
>> Sure. But when under normal
circumstances I do have a normal color
you know that I associate with the BTT
now not so much color for me with the
3.0.
>> I really and I missed it you know when I
when I switched to 3.0 I was like oh
>> so sometimes I'll get the 3.0 I don't
know, but I'll add some BTT just to, you
know, but also um always I recommend
adding extra minerals.
>> Yes,
>> especially with the 3.0.
>> That's another chart. I got another
chart, but I won't show any more charts.
>> Right. Right. Well, fortunately, uh she
did do that, so at least we got those in
in addition to uh the BTT. though I you
know some people just at least they're
getting some in not the same quantity as
the the powders but they want the tablet
form and at least they're you know at
least they're trying to uh start the
process of neutrifying their body. Uh, I
try I I do sometimes use the onthe-go
packs as the entry product sometimes
and um, you know, people love just to
get them in the habit, right?
>> Right.
>> Of the nutrition, but
I do try to emphasize you're not getting
the full dose of I I told somebody now
we've got enough nutrition in you for
your left leg.
right from the on the-go pack. So, we
need we need nutrition for your whole
body. So,
>> and then you know the powder is the
upgrade
from
>> Yeah.
I I love that comment. I love the
comment. Excuse me. The the second
question I had is um you mentioned the
urine strips which I didn't realize they
had so many multi- uh test strips. I
know of the kind of two colors versus
the six or so that you showed on that.
Um my question is on the pH of the
urine. Is there a um I guess target or
recommended pH? I know there's probably
a whole
>> I love that question. That is such a
good question
because people spend people when I say
people a lot of companies
market
tests of pH
>> of the urine and they'll tell you if
you're acidic or if you're alkaline you
>> no
>> they can't tell that you cannot tell
that from the urine I hope I can okay so
when we say that the body is a little
alkaline
that's the blood
>> and the urine the kidneys are what help
to keep the blood alkaline
>> Mhm. Mhm.
>> So if there's some extra stress going on
or if there's anything, you know, the
blood starts to get a little close to
normal, a little less alkaline than we
want it, the urine is going to flush out
that extra acid.
>> So the fact that the urine is acidic
does not say what the blood is. Mhm.
>> So if there's a acid in the urine,
that's your body keeping your blood in a
normal pH.
>> Okay. And would you say that in your
interpretation more acidic is worse than
kind of let's call it, you know, let's
say the five which is fairly acidic for
urine to maybe six or 6.5.
>> Yeah. You you don't want to have that
kind of stress, right?
>> Okay. But your kid could and I'll talk
about your kidneys are amazing
>> as far as um
I call it the adjustment bureau. The the
tubules of the kidneys, you know that
movie has nothing to do with the movie.
I just like the title.
>> But your kidneys can adjust to multiple
environments and it can adapt. But the
whole function
is to keep your body in homeostasis in
dynamic equilibrium
and it is a beautiful thing. So
um a highly acidic urine that might mean
that there's a lot of stress going on
and we want to have a better environment
in the body but that does not mean that
your blood is acidic.
>> Right. Right? Because it
>> if your blood gets acidic, then you're
talking metabolic acidosis. That's bad,
right? And if it's too alkaline, which
you can have metabolic alkyossis,
>> bad.
We got to have, we want to have our pH,
it's a go, it's one of the Goldilocks
measurements. We It has to be just
right. and our kidneys help our blood pH
to stay just right.
>> Got it. Thank you. Thank you. I'll turn
it over to Ruth Ellen to manage the
questions.
>> Thank you very much, Mary. And we have
Yinia with her hand up. So, Yinia, if
you can unmute yourself and then I have
a question from Facebook or YouTube, I'm
sorry.
>> Thank you. I have a quick question. So
when um when you when you're going
through menopause or post-menopause,
will your urine be different?
>> I'm just writing that down. Um
I don't have a Let me think. I would
have to think about that. But um
when anytime your metabolism is
different
then your urine is going to help to
compensate. So I could see I could see
episodes when that is uh the case. But
if you would allow me I can do a little
research and and you know see if I can
find research articles that actually
correlate the two. Yeah, that will be
fine. And then I do I have time, Ruth
Ellen, to just give a quick um testimony
real quick.
>> Yes.
>> Okay. Um I went to get my haircut uh
just a couple of days ago and just a
trim and I was very surprised that I
mean I it really surprised me that the
my hairdresser said, "You know, you have
a lot of growing hair like a lot in the
top area." She said the bottom is thin
but you have so much growing hair and I
thought the only thing that I'm doing is
taking the um the 90 essential
nutrients. That's it. Um so I went home
and I thought you know I'm at I'm at I'm
already in menopause. So I thought you
know what that is the number one thing
that we had that I remembered looking at
that I was uh every time I would bathe I
would sh you know I would wash my hair I
would shed some hair but when the my
hairdresser said that I it made me
really happy so I just wanted to share
that. Thank you.
>> Thank you. That's fantastic news.
>> Yay. Wonderful.
>> I'm so excited for you.
That's wonderful. Wonderful.
I love stories like that.
I do the slightest, you know, just your
hair growing and that that's huge
actually. It's really huge. It's not a
little thing. It's big. So, be great.
You know, says, "I'm just happy and
grateful for you." All righty. Um so we
have an interesting question from
YouTube from Olga and she says when
colorful urine le when colorful urine
leaves the body through the urinary
tract do those nutrients feed the
tissues they are passing through.
At that point they have already done the
feeding
>> and um what happens in the kidney
tubules
if nutrients are in the blood that are
filtered out
there are there's an area in the kidney
tubules that reabsorbs the good stuff.
>> Nice.
>> It's amazing. And so it it's like, oh
no, you you're trying to get escape. No,
you can't escape. We're we're going to
reabsorb you back into the body. And
then maybe a couple of passes later
after the good stuff has done its job,
then it's going to um
allow it to leave the body. So once it's
left, it's already done its work.
That is fascinating.
The kidneys are amazing. Oh my gosh.
>> That Wow, that's really amazing. My mind
has been blown.
>> That's at the distal convoluted tubules.
If you want to look it up, the DCT
is where it reabsorbs
um the good stuff that's filtered
through and the body's like, "Oh, no. We
we need that. Let's bring that back.
We'll let the water go. We'll let the,
you know, the waste go. We'll let the pH
the extra acid ions go. But we need
that.
>> That's amazing. Absolutely amazing.
Who would have thought?
Okay, let me see if there's any other um
questions anywhere. Um hello Harry
Flying Angel. He's sending blessings.
Dr. Lisa,
>> thank you.
>> And he says, "Great information."
And then um Mr. RR O W or DW I should
say. Hello Rumble Nation.
This Oh gosh, this topic by Dr.
Singleary is so timely and needed.
>> Thank you. Amen. Amen.
>> It is because we kind of ignore kidneys
to a certain point. Yeah,
>> we always focus on like the liver and
the gallbladder and the different things
and sometimes
I mean your um podcast from last
Saturday,
I never knew 90%. Oh boy, I shouldn't
say that. I didn't know like 60% of what
you talked about with the kidneys
because you just Dr. Wallick always
talks about you have these little tiny
capillaries and they're like microscopic
and they get clogged and you showed them
and I was like what?
>> Yeah, there's a whole another
>> there's a whole another capillary system
in the kidneys that's the low pressure
from you know around the tubules but
those glamoli
they are they are um under attack.
They're under siege by
>> wow
>> high blood pressure and by high blood
sugar.
>> So
>> that's amazing.
>> And so someone shared um at some point
uh or Dr. Wallica has shared how
sometimes urine um or people with kidney
failure
their kidneys are taken out and they're
normal
but it's not be it's because or the
kidney tissue is normal but the glow
marial line
are damaged which means the the fluid
you know everything downstream
there's a problem but the actual ual
kidney function would be normal
if we could take care of those little
glomeial.
Wow, that's amazing. I
Yeah, my mind's Okay, we have another
question from Becca Dukes. Hey there,
Becca.
>> Becca,
>> yes. She would like to know Dr. Lisa's
thoughts about the practice of drinking
one's own urine.
Practice of drinking one's own urine is
most commonly known as europasia
in the context of alternative medicine.
It is frequently referred to as urine
therapy or eurotherapy.
>> Yeah, I can't get with that. And I have
I I promise you I have not looked it up.
I've heard about it. But that's just
knowing that the function of the kidneys
is part of your excretory
system and it's to excrete or get rid of
from the body the waste products.
Hey, show me an article. I'll read the
article. I still won't drink my urine.
Now there are um we had many stories
about
people doing surgery under extreme
conditions like no running water and
they would you know get a little kid to
come and urinate and that would be how
they wash the instruments or things like
that. But um assuming that that was that
that their urine was sterile,
that was a little
stretch for me, but I understood it
especially after multiple trips to
Africa. So it's like, okay, I can see.
But um yeah,
>> I know,
you know, and like I said, I've had a an
alopathically trained brain. I admit it.
So I'm on the journey to understanding
and uh the natural and alternative
therapies. Now, one thing that was very
instrumental in my
opening my mind, I guess to um
alternative medicine
was I I actually bought a book, a
textbook called alternative medicine and
it was like this thick big book and
there was this one sentence
in
the book that was I was reading a
chapter on energy medicine because I was
trying to understand I was trying to
wrap my mind around Reiki and you know
different energy healing and there was
this one line in the book that says all
medicine is energy medicine
and I was like you know you're right
because I used to teach physics so I
understand there's chemical energy
there's physical ical energy there's
sound energy. So if you're given a
medication that is chemical
energy
happening in the body. So that like
unlocked the door of my mind to learn
about alternative medicine. But it's
going to take a whole another door to
unlock
euro what is it? Urine therapy.
So
>> oh I just haven't studied it. So
>> yes Rebecca says lol. I'm with you, Dr.
Lisa.
Yeah, I'm gonna have a hard time. I
mean, I've heard of people who have been
like stranded in the desert and drank
their urine just to keep themselves
hydrated. And I can totally understand
that.
>> Yeah.
>> And you know, maybe I would do that if I
was in that between life or death, but I
just can't. I'm I'm with you. And I know
that there's a whole group of people
that believe in drinking their urine and
bathing in their urine and
>> Yeah, I've heard of it. I've heard of
it, but I haven't studied it. So,
>> now we have one more hand up. Did you
have a hard stop? I forgot to ask you.
I'm just
>> I'm good.
>> Okay. All right, Marilyn.
Oops. I'm sorry.
You're muted.
I accidentally hit unmute when you mute
it and whatever.
>> Okay. I just want to say that I have had
ozone therapy and I have had urine
therapy but not where you drink it but
they inject it to you and I had it I did
it for like 3 months and I felt
incredibly well incredibly increased
energy through the ozone and the urine
therapy. Now, what I was told was that
your body produces specific antigens
that are specific to your body. And when
you reintroduce it back in, your body
produces antibodies to those specific
antigens.
And this was it was down in Mexico. Um,
it was a doctor. He was he was an
American doctor, but he was practicing
down there. And anyway, I did it. And
they had you have to have a special
filter that filters out, you know, like
E.coli coli and salmonila some of the
bad bacteria but the other the antigens
are so small that they seep through and
they get through the filter but the
filter traps yeah you know the bad
bacteria that cannot be reintroduced
back into the body
anyway that's
>> I get it
>> thank you Marilyn
>> I'm scared but I get it
I'm fine I'm
I did three months like every day they
did it.
>> This is okay. So this is again the body
is amazing right and this is one of the
things I didn't explain quite so well
when I was talking about earning the
aristocracy but if you consider the
venus blood your waste blood the
oxygenated blood is the fully you know
fully stoked up souped up blood. Um,
by the time your blood goes through, by
the time your red blood cells go
through, the capillaries
deposit the oxygen that the capillaries
that the tissues need and start
circulating back to the heart to go to
the lungs. Um, it's only 75%.
It still has 75%
of the oxygen carrying capacity.
So, quote unquote, the waste
blood is still jam-packed with, you
know, great things, including oxygen.
So,
the body's amazing. So, hats off to the
people that, you know, are learning
more and more of the ways that we can
nourish and support the body.
Yeah. Thank you, Marilyn.
Um,
I I just um I'm sorry. I still
I just don't know if I could do that,
but I know a lot of people that do, and
I have some clients that do that type of
therapy. So,
um, thank you so much, Dr. Lisa, it's
been wonderful. I can't wait for your
next talk. Are you going to go deeper
into the kidneys maybe?
>> Oh, yeah. I There's a lot to talk about
in these kidneys, these tubules and
y secretion and all the things. Yep.
>> Very good.
>> Countercurrent multiplication.
Don't get me started. Okay.
>> Oh my gosh. I don't even know what that
is.
It's how your kidneys make your urine
can can make it either dark dark yellow
concentrated
>> or light light yellow depending on your
hydration status. It's like how does
that happen
countercurren multiplication?
>> I can't wait. That sounds fascinating.
It does.
>> It is.
Well, thank you so much for everything
and um being on the show with us and um
can't wait till your next visit.
I'm excited. And then you um you did
share the link to your podcast on
YouTube
and um can you give us
>> Dr. Lisa Singleary is the
>> Okay.
>> channel, Dr. Lisa Singleary.
>> Perfect. All right. Very good. And if I
could get my co-host to come back on the
screen with me, then we can wrap up the
show. And um I want to thank everybody
for joining us today. It's always
amazing information. I'm so grateful to
be part of this team and doing this
work.
It's very rewarding.
So, if you would like to join our team
and um have any questions about that,
please give us a call at 855-9493377
or you can email us at
questionsailywithdoc.com.
And again, this program was for
educational purposes only. And um
tomorrow Rebecca Dukes is going to be
your host because she is back home and
back in Pennsylvania.
Yeehaw. Welcome home, Rebecca. I've
missed you terribly. Um and she's going
to have a special guest tomorrow. Um,
I believe it is Carrie Scott is going to
be joining her with a fascinating story
about her child's return to wellness and
um, it's going to be really good.
Also,
I think I'm Oh, I know. I think I did
that. I did that. Okay. So
please
be kind to people and know that
everybody is going through something
different. So just be kind and make sure
you say hi too because sometimes that
can save a life as well. You hear
stories. So, um, so our fabulous team
that is with us today is, uh, Sherry,
who is part of the tech crew, and she
helps set up everything
going out into YouTube and everywhere. I
send the signal to there, Sherry, and
she sends it out. So, thank you for
that, Sherry. And then we have Mary Mary
who has helped us yesterday doing beady
fingers to the best of her abilities and
today she was out there on the different
platforms bringing in questions. And Sue
Dell on Facebook I did post the link to
the um multistrip blood in your in like
you asked. So I didn't want you to think
I didn't do that in the different chats
here. So thank you for that. And Mary
you're awesome
also. Marilyn, glad that you are feeling
better today and that you're here doing
um your magic with the keyboard. So,
thank you, thank you, thank you. And we
have Albert who is here with us from
South Africa and he is the person that's
going to answer the phone team uh phone
number in the middle of the night. And
so, if you get somebody with his
fantastic out accent, that is him. He is
our gatekeeper and a true gentleman.
true sense of the word, gentleman. Love
him. And then we have Rod, who is not on
camera, but has been out there posting
and bringing questions in and uh letting
me know that there was a question that I
missed. So, thank you for that. Also,
AJ, who's not on the screen today in his
he is our digital marketing director and
or manager, I'm sorry. And thank you so
much for all that you do. And another
huge welcome and thank you, Dr. Lisa,
I'm so grateful that you are here today
and I look forward to having a
conversation with you maybe later today.
So everybody um enjoy your weekend. Oh
no, sorry. I'm the one leaving. You guys
are enjoy seeing you tomorrow. So enjoy
your evening and then um looking forward
to Rebecca being back on screen. See you
later. Bye everybody.
This program is for educational purposes
only. The content is not intended to
diagnose, treat, cure, or prevent any
diseases, nor is it intended to take the
place of your primary care physician.
The statements in this program have not
been evaluated by the FDA. Testimonials
are shared as individual experiences of
the individual. Results vary and may not
be typical. We do not make any claims
regarding health or income. As an
empowered individual, you do have
options available. We are honored to
continue to share the teachings of a
founding father of the science of
epigenetics. Dr. Joel Wallik, Bachelor
of Science in Plant and Soil Sciences,
Doctor of Veterary Medicine, four
post-doates and pathology, naturopathic
doctor.